well we have a big win for Hobby Lobby a
big win for a lot of the pro-life
advocates that you see rallying here
behind me the decision was announced a
huge cheer went up it was a five-to-four
decision before the supreme court ruling
that Hobby Lobby a privately held
company with religious owners could be
exempt from this provision of the
Affordable Care Act that requires or
required until today that employees
receive coverage including all forms of
fda-approved contraception hobby lobby's
had it disagreed with two forms of
contraception saying that they amounted
to abortion and now it appears that the
Supreme Court today again in a
five-to-four decision is allowing hobby
lobby to opt out of that part of the law
again a victory for Hobby Lobby today
Justice Alito reading the decision from
the bench I'm still reading in on this
decision but it does seem like it is a
victory for Hobby Lobby today and Megan
there were some other cases that came
out today one particular in relation to
unions tell us what happened there yeah
so it this was a decision out of
Illinois and it was a blow to the unions
that found that workers don't aren't
allowed to be required to have part of
their paychecks taken out to go to the
unions now this was a small group of
workers home health care workers in
Illinois and the justices had a narrow
decision here so it was a blow to the
public unions in general but they
phrased it though this was a certain
type of worker they weren't full fledged
public employees so it could have been a
much bigger hit two unions across the
board around the country a narrow
decision but it was certainly a hit to
unions to